2020 glauben sie noch es geschafft zu
haben das US-Unternehmen Virgin
hyperloop schießt zwei Menschen durch
eine Vakuumröhre es ist die erste
Passagierfahrt in einem hyperloop sie
träumen vom Reisen mit
Schallgeschwindigkeit noch in diesem
jahrzehn doch nur zwei Jahre später
schmeißt die Firma die halbe Belegschaft
raus und verabschiedet sich vom Traum
der verkehrsrevolution seinem Traum es
ist eine Mischung zwischen der Concord
einem schienengewehr und einem Luf
hockeytisch in Deutschland steht
inzwischen der erste hyperloop geht der
Traum von der verkehrsrevolution also
hier
weiter 2013 hebt Elon Musk das Konzept
ursprünglich auf die Bühne der Tech
Milliardär stellt seine Idee von
Fernreisen vor in einem White Paper
einer Skizze Kapseln Rasen mit 1000 kmh
von A nach B und das mit grünem
Strom als moderner Mensch hat er jetzt
nicht gesagt okay ich mach das selber
sondern in einer Art open Session open
innovation ist er losgezogen hat die
ganze Welt gefragt könnte nicht
mithelfen und so ist das entstanden Musk
veranstaltet Wettbewerbe auf seinem
SpaceX
Gelände Startups und Unis weltweit
Ringen um die schnellste hyperloop
Kapsel und die Studierenden der TU
München gewinnen ja für
ja auch gabrieleino damals noch als
Student bei maskwettkämpfen
dabei das war natürlich besonders wenn
man immer immer wenn man jemand trifft
immer vielleicht aus dem Fernsehen aus
dem Buch oder was auch immer kennt es
ist natürlich eine besondere Erfahrung
das war auch sehr interessant sich mit
ihm auszutauschen damals der wollte
immer sehr technisch reden der technisch
mit uns diskutieren was haben wir gebaut
warum haben wir das so gemacht warum
haben wir das nicht anders gemacht mask
selbst zieht sich zunächst zurück nur
seine ominöse boring company tüftet im
Hintergrund Grund weiter dazu
gleich denn seine Idee ist inzwischen
trotzdem Realität zumindest auf einer
Strecke von 24
m Gabriele semine und sein Team haben
das Konzept in München
weiterentwickelt der TUM hyperloop steht
so könnte also das Reisen der Zukunft
aussehen hoffen
sie von den Sachen die paper drin waren
ist vieles jetzt anders was wir was nur
übrig geblieben ist ist dieser Name
hyperloop und diese Idee eben Menschen
in einer vakuumröhe sehr schnell zu
bewegen wie man das aber genau umsetzt
technisch das hat sich komplett geändert
also vom schwebesystem zum
amtriebssystem wir nutzen heute andere
Technologien bessere andere
Konfigurationen die aus sehr vielen
Überlegungen kommen seitdem wie kriegt
man dieses Thema dieses sehr schnellen
Transport von Menschen technisch besser
umgesetzt neun Monate lang haben sie die
Röhre gebaut und vor Ort auch zum Teil
selbstgefertigt all das für 4 Millionen
Euro finanziert vom bayerischen
Freistart im Sommer 2023 bewegt sich
dann etwas es sieht zwar nach wenig aus
aber sie kontrollieren hier gerade die
erste bemannte hyperloopfahrt in Europa
3 Jahre nach der Jungfernfahrt in den
USA das Prinzip bleibt gleich in der
Röhre erzeugen Sie ein Vakuum um den
Luftwiderstand zu verringern durch
Magnetismus wird die gesamte Kapsel dann
angehoben und schwebt dadurch minimieren
Sie weiter die Reibung der Motor
befindet sich nicht in der Kapsel
sondern in der Strecke ein sogenannter
linearotor wie das hier funktioniert ist
dass man eben diesen Linearmotor auf dem
Boden hat Heß durch diesen Linearmotor
kann bestromt werden und erzeugt eine
Art magnetische Welle die den
Permanentmagnet der in der Kapsel ist
anzieht und mitzieht und dadurch kann
die Kapsel bewegt werden können und
solchen Motor muss man wahrscheinlich
über großen Teils der Strecke haben dass
die Kapsel durchgängig auf erstmal
beschleunigt wird und dann auf
konstanter Geschwindigkeit gehalten
werden kann das Prinzip an sich ist
nicht ganz neu und erinnert an den
Transrapid die transporthoffnung der
2000er deutlich schneller als ein
normaler ICE gebaut auf speziellen
Strecken ohne Vakuumröhre aber mit
parallelen zum hyperlop
Idee des transrapides ist es auf einem
magnetkissen zu schweben und allein aus
der Antwort sieht man schon das Problem
beim transped sind dann die Kosten eine
Brücke zu bauen ist relativ teuer
Magnettechnik über viele Kilometer hin
weg in so eine Brücke hinein zu legen
ist auch teuer t Sikes hat den
Transrapid mitentwickelt und forscht
heute zu neuen Schienenfahrzeugen am
deutschen Luft und Raumfahrtzentrum er
glaubt der hyperloop könnte wie der
Transrapid auf dem abstörle
landen denn der hyperloop bräuchte nicht
nur eine magnetische Bahn wie der
Transrapid sondern eine ganze Röhre um
sich und die Kapseln transportieren nach
Schätzungen nur ein paar Dutzend
Passagiere wie kann das dann günstiger
werden eine Sache ist günstig einer
Sache ist effizient das sind ja zwei
unterschiedliche Begriffe wir achten
sehr drauf dass diese andere die wir uns
überlegen im Bau dann günstiger ist als
die Konfiguration vom Transrapid
andererseits hat man zusätzlich Aspekt
des Vakuums was natürlich im Bau erstmal
mit gewissen Mehrkosten kommt aber
langfristig für einen
energieeffizienteren Transport sorgt
denn dadurch dass man in gewissen in
geringeren Luftdruck ist hat man
geringeren Luftwiderstand und kann sich
dadurch mit weniger Energie bewegen ein
weiteres Problem um von 0 auf 1000 h zu
beschleunigen braucht der hyperloop eine
lange gerade und ebene Strecke also ohne
höhenabweichungen auch deswegen hält
sievkes das Konzept nicht für machbar in
dicht besiedelten Regionen wie z.B
Deutschland hyperloopstcke in
Deutschland lässt sich nicht umsetzen
weil wir brauchen für den hyperloop sehr
gerade Strecken sehr gerade Strecken
geht oberirdisch nicht oberirdisch sind
wir sehr dicht bebaut in Deutschland das
heißt das geht nur unterirdisch man
müsste Tunnel buddeln für den hyperloop
diese Tunnel müssten relativ lang sein
weil ein hyperloop auf 1000
Stundenkilometer zu beschleunigen
braucht eine ganze gute Strecke und ihm
dann wieder abzubremsen auf 0
Stundenkilometer brauch noch mal eine
ganz gute Strecke dann muss man wirklich
schon sich so
eine Magistrale Berlin München angucken
und dann wird es einfach von den Kosten
überhaupt nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig zu
dem was wir auf der Schiene tun sie
geschätzt 1 km hyperloop kostet doppelt
so viel wie ein ICE da könne man gleich
das bewrte Zugsystem verbessern statt
eine neue Infrastruktur zu
bauen an der TU hoffen sie dagegen
weiter dass der hyperloop irgendwann
preislich mit dem ICE gleich Zehen
könnte mit dem gleichen Argument hätte
man sich damals wo man die erste
Eisenbahn hatte auch denken können im
Flugzeug brauchen wir nicht wir können
auf jeden Fall immer die Eisenbahn
bisschen schneller machen wir erforschen
hier am hyperloom und wollen beweisen
dass man das System technisch umsetzen
kann dass es sicher ist und dass es auch
wirtschaftlich sinnvoll ist zu bauen
wenn uns das nicht gelingen sollten und
wen wir merken sollten dass es nicht
klappt dann ist es auch nicht sinnvoll
umzusetzen dann macht es nicht Sinn für
mich auch als Steuerzahler zu sagen nee
sowas sollte man nicht bauen in München
suchen Sie bereits ein neues Gelände für
eine noch längere
teströhre aber was hat eigentlich Elon
Musk
gemacht der hat bislang statt eines
hyperloops nur einen sogenannten Loop
gebaut ein unterirdischer Tunnel in Las
Vegas in dem Teslas hin und her fahren
manche sprechen von einem
marketingc